[Musique]
les répétitions se multiplient la saison
virtuelle des fêtes d'entreprise sur le
point de commencer
d'habitude ces musiciens se produisent
devant public en salle cette année les
spectateurs resteront chez eux mais
apparaîtront sur un écran géant on est
très très très occupé en ce moment les
dirigeants de sociétés sont nombreux à
faire appel à kuyt d'etion une
entreprise qui se spécialise dans
l'événementiel pour animer leur
réception de noël
on va utiliser une plateforme de
diffusion qu'on a créé donc on va mettre
des banh des humoristes l on va intégrer
des mixologue avec ça ceux qui croient
qu'une soirée musicale zoom n'a rien de
palpitant ne sont que des sceptiques qui
seront confondus soutient michel mais un
élément d'interaction qu'il n'y avait
pas d'ailleurs dans le côté présentiel
de la chose parce que les gens
maintenant peuvent interagir en direct
avec les musiciens sur scène en leur
demandant demandes spéciales
les spectacles ont lieu en direct ou
sons préenregistrés pour les clients qui
ont des bureaux dans plusieurs pays
qui dit célébration dit aussi repas cuit
internationa ses entrées chez le
traiteur agnus dei avec qui il prépare
un grand spectacle pour des milliers de
convives en u certains événements dont 1
2500 livraison le même jour qu'on aura à
faire pendant décembre en même temps
parce que l'événement lui ne peut pas
attendre
cette année pour les mets qui seront mis
en boîte david carrier a opté pour un
concept qui reflète bien la nuit les ont
donc ce niveau à l'envers donc ça
commence par le dessert une bûche de
foie gras et de magret de canard par
exemple et ça redescend jusque ensuite
jusqu'à l'entrée de nombreuses
entreprises québécoises 7 auront noël
avec les employés cette année plus que
jamais on est vraiment décidé de
chouchouter un petit peu plus ses
employés on sait que ça a été une année
très difficile pour certains et l'équipe
en somme on décide qu'on allait faire un
zoom virtuel avec une thématique en fait
qui est sorti ses bals de finissants
vidéo balle efficace une transition
c'est pour passer à une autre étape
c'est ce qu'on soit tout le monde ici
aussi vivement que l'année se termine en
musique les préférences ici maxime
bertrand radio-canada mourir